hello grace helbig welcome to my serious
monologue psych hey guys welcome to
Saturday eree sorry they didn't edit
this video yesterday well it's up now
and a lot of things have happened this
week been on set for a lecturer woman
and Dyna girl all we kind of heart and I
you don't know Saturday re is a look
back at my week blog style so let's look
at some stuff this happened one day two
of a shoot with YouTube
can you tell also this is here not for
me yet Green Revolution is in a place
that is
they remade my house look the betters
look what what what look at this couch
but what what what what what what what
what the added a guy look at this what
this is weird
right yes
fake office it's a fake office the fake
office as as as as as is also this
happened
oh good morning Fred hurry it is Monday
morning and hearts in the background a
beautiful silhouette it's 6:00 a.m. oh
we're headed to set and it's raining
it's just such a mood enhancer raishin
he gets it with us Monty Monty's our
driver he dies every almost every day
and get paid for I think it's paid for
it and gets to listen to us like just
flop around and talk not sense
unfiltered let's start a workweek a oh
I've been in Canada too long Wow green
room look at this Oh someone's missing a
thing seems a shot of the day very
impressive I have to drive a car seat
steering wheel indicates car this car
has it been taken to a car wash ever how
would you describe the smell I'm pitch
rubber rubber armpit like a second ago
we were talking about how if gray start
vomiting if I make it better
oh your hair looks hilarious why
me that's me tell me what this is Brett
Brett can't Brett can Brett can't and
Brett and Brett is responsible for
making sure Hannah and I go to the
places that we're supposed to go
which is a hard duty for him because
we're just like two tethered children
are you doing a great job Brett showing
people what they watch from the
moneymaker Brett a mid like oh yeah
there it is
you're backlit so beautiful whoa get
ready for this stuff what a beautiful
tree
in a building what not to be too TMI but
just so you guys know this is what
ladies have to wear under form-fitting
superhero suits to make sure everything
is okay and not weird and oh yeah
that's for me
my driver told me that the last person
that was in his car was beyond
yeah come to the set I said the joke too
early I planned a Beyonce gag Anya just
wait are you serious I want you to watch
your thing online last night like
everyone this is Andy Andy plays I care
so your real job of faster and you plays
with your heart is well whoa whoa whoa
whoa also this is Chris he's a camera
guy loves his job having a great time
there's George being hilarious George
pulls focus guys most focus guy on set
what a dream director Chris this is
Brendan DP yeah that's a piece of [ __ ]
over there trying to hide your costume
there's been an update to Hannah's chair
here's my chair
here's Hannah's chair hey I hope you
have a catcher's mitt because I'm
throwing this at you hello good morning
welcome to day seven onset of electro
one and diner girl we're gonna go in for
blocking just got hair and makeup done
blocking means let me go find out where
we stand and how we walk in the scene
then we come back to put on the spandex
and then we go back and film the scene
let's go do some blocking
Silas is absolutely no access right
there
no we're blocking how's your day Andy Oh
our green room got an upgrade and Brett
is just taking over your oops don't mind
me just put my feet up classic bread
here comes trouble
hello it is day 8 here on set day
feeling great day 8 feeling great and
we're getting ready to shoot the first
scene of the day there's a lot of
commotion on set today there's a lot of
people we're shooting a party scene it's
very exciting business TGIF party party
party party party party party party
party party party party party if this
room doesn't scream party I don't know
what does hello it is 12:20 a.m. and
we're still filming I can't show you
what we're filming because it would be
spoilers there's Nicole Nicole does our
wardrobe and she's so great important
update that's beard can because they all
have beers that's happening there
there's a camera at the end of that
let's do it
those guys are doing something Vicky's
making some fake cocktails right now no
these guys did yes so Fant
there you go that's everything that
happened this week I hope that you
enjoyed it don't forget that hmm I need
to tell you one you're great too
subscribe if you want to be a part of
something here and like this video if
you liked it cuz that's a very cool way
of me getting positive feedback and
feeling good for a brief fleeting moment
also go to electro Medina girl calm &
sign up so you can get updates on the
project as it happens and if you want to
see more up-to-date things happening in
my life phone and snapchat real grace
Helbig this is a lot of information I
don't know
also also hey USA season 2 is happening
I don't know if you knew that but here's
a link to the video that may mermaid
announcing what's happening season two
basically we need your help and she
explains it all there and I'm there with
her explaining it so go watch that this
is me getting everyone involved without
showing your costumes yeah it's a video
guys